[MUSIC PLAYING]
SOWMYA KANNAN: Welcome
to Cloud OnAir,
live webinars from Google Cloud.
We are hosting webinars daily.
You're watching Cloud
101, where speakers
discuss the fundamental concepts
of Google Cloud Platform
and learn from the best
practices in different markets.
My name is Sowmya Kannan.
And today, we will be talking
about Kickstarting Your Career
in Google Cloud.
Joining me today is Evan Jones.
You can ask questions
anytime on the platform.
And we have Googlers on
standby to answer them.
So let's get started.
EVAN JONES: Let's do it.
SOWMYA KANNAN: All right.
Let's get started with
a presentation here.
And so Evan, you want
to introduce yourself?
EVAN JONES: Sure.
For those of you who
haven't seen my face before,
I'm a Big Data Machine Learning
Technical Curriculum Developer.
It's a mouthful to say.
But honestly, it's a dream job.
I get to tinker away and
build some really cool labs.
And the best part is we get to
present them all for you today.
So not to give away a little
bit of the agenda later,
but what we're
going to be doing is
playing a live interactive
game with prizes.
So make sure if you really want
to get the most out of this,
you definitely want
to stick around
for that game at the end.
SOWMYA KANNAN: Woo!
All right.
My name is Sowmya Kannan.
I'm the Global Lead for Google
Cloud Learning and Higher Ed.
My focus is to enable
students in higher education
to tap into careers
in cloud with training
and certification.
EVAN JONES: So for
the agenda for today,
we're going to talk a little
bit about careers in the cloud.
I'll share my past experience
of how I got to Google Cloud
in general.
And we're going to share how
literally in this webinar
right now, through this game
and a couple of the labs
you're going to
play, you can start
to develop those skills
that will get you
on the path to building
a career in the cloud.
And Sowmya is also going to
share some really cool stats
of if you get cloud
certified or if you practice
a lot of these labs, it
actually has a tangible impact
in the marketplace for your next
career, which is really cool.
I'll show you some neat demos.
If you've never seen Google
Cloud Platform before,
there's some really
neat things that you
can do with machine learning,
with Kubernetes, with BigQuery.
So you're going to see
a bunch of cool demos,
and I've hand-selected five
labs as part of our game for you
to play along with us today.
At any time during
this webinar, I
see some folks are already
typing in the live chat,
and that makes me
extremely happy.
So we get the presentation
on this laptop,
but we also have the
live chat over here,
so I'm super thrilled to
get people from Istanbul.
So if you wouldn't mind right
now, just say hi in that chat.
We have Nandini
who's standing by
to answer any of
your questions live.
But also the cool
thing is if you
have a question that we don't
answer during today's session,
you can post it to
that thread, and then
Sowmya or I will go
in after the fact
and make sure you get those
links with those resources,
especially because later
on in the presentation,
there's going to be a
promotional link that's
going to give you 30
free days of Qwiklabs.
So in addition to your 12 hour
game today, which is all free,
you can stick around to get
that 30 free day link as well.
And we'll post that into
this discussion thread.
But before that, we
need to teach you
a bunch of really, really
cool stuff and why it matters.
So first and foremost,
I'm going to talk
to you about a little
bit of my path to Google.
A lot of people
wonder, how did you
end up at Google in a job
in Google in Google Cloud?
So I went to the college
University of Maryland.
It's on the east
coast in the US.
And my first major
was accounting.
I'm like, oh, man,
this is great.
I love working with numbers.
And I was sitting in my 300
person accounting class,
and I decided, hm, doing a
lot of this stuff by hand
is super hard.
So my first information
systems class,
it really showed me
the power of computing,
and how I can take
a lot of this logic
and feed it into an
automated system.
And I basically learned the
language of the Structured
Query Language, or SQL.
And I absolutely
fell in love with it.
I could write queries
and build dashboards,
really just let the computer
do all the hard work,
which is pretty fun.
So if you've ever
worked with spreadsheets
or any kind of application
before where there's data,
you know that you can unlock
the power of that data
by using a query language that
you're going to be learning
a little bit more of today.
After that, I worked for
a renewable energy company
and then really realized
that I wasn't physical goods.
I actually worked for a
solar panel manufacturer,
and I ended up dropping
one of the solar panels.
So I was just like,
I'm better for sticking
in the digital world, where
I can't really-- well, I can
break things, but less easily.
And you can always roll
back the code as well.
So then I joined a consulting
firm in DC, Deloitte,
which was really, really fun.
But that eventually
led me to Google.
My first job was in Google
Finance building pipelines.
And then I eventually got
a job in Google Cloud.
And the really cool
thing about cloud is--
let me tell you a
little bit of a story.
In my first database class,
flashback to the year 2008.
It was junior in college.
And the professor, Dr.
Weiss, was talking to me
about how do you
set up a schema,
how do you load data in.
And what struck me was
really interesting,
is we were using Microsoft
Access at the time.
And in the performance
optimization section,
he had to warn the class, OK,
now you run the query first,
and then you run
the query first,
and then only use a
subset of the data,
just so you can get
an idea for the query.
In the back of my mind,
I'm like, why couldn't we
all run the same query at once?
Why can't we all use
a gigantic data set?
Why am I limited by my hardware,
that my physical machine,
either on my laptop or
some server back there?
And then lo and behold,
a lot of other people
were having that problem.
And then Google and a bunch
of other cloud providers
have created these
fully managed services.
Like, if you've ever
heard of BigQuery before,
you don't need to worry
about stacking in servers
or managing any of the hardware.
You just need to
remember the SQL,
how to ask those
questions of your data.
And all the hardware, and
all the querying power,
and all the infrastructure
is managed for you by Google
behind the scenes.
So instead of you managing
things and worrying
about things like concurrency
or too many people
hitting your
application, you can
let Google manage that
and build on Google Stack.
So that was really
interesting, kind
of full circle from
10 years of running
a database in my
laptop, to running
a database in a bunch of
data centers around the world
that I don't need to see, and
I don't need to worry about.
You're going to be using
BigQuery today in your lab.
That's essentially what
Google Cloud allows you to do.
You bring the great ideas.
Google Cloud, literally the
word is Google Cloud Platform.
It builds you that platform.
It makes those resources
available to you.
All these fun icons
that you see here
are all the different
technologies that you
can reach out and access.
Google had to build them
for itself to solve--
if you remember,
Google's mission
is to make the information
of the world universally
accessible.
So it had to solve
it for itself,
so then it created those
technologies available to you
for you to use on this platform.
So some stats by the numbers--
I always like
throwing these out.
In case you're wondering how
big is Google Cloud Platform
and Google as a whole,
over 1.2 billion photos
are uploaded every
day, for those of you
who use Google Photos.
SOWMYA KANNAN: That's amazing.
EVAN JONES: That's crazy, right?
SOWMYA KANNAN: Mind
boggling size, yeah.
EVAN JONES: It's a total
size of-- if you haven't
seen PB before, so it's
megabyte, gigabyte, terabyte,
which is 1,000 gigabytes,
and 1,000 terabytes
is one petabyte.
And then you've got
exabytes, and zetabytes,
and that sort of thing.
But that's 13 petabytes of data.
If you're looking at the other
stat if you're a YouTuber,
1 petabyte or over 400 hours
of video, end-to-end video,
is uploaded to
YouTube every minute.
It would literally
take a lifetime
to start watching
all the videos that
were uploaded in a day or two.
So it's crazy, too.
And all that, think
about the infrastructure
needed to maintain Google
Photos and YouTube.
That's what's available to
you for your applications
with Google Cloud Platform.
And you'll experience that
within your lab a little bit
later today.
Also in addition to
the infrastructure,
there's all the networking.
So the networking is all the
cables and the technology
that allows the internet's
traffic through Google
to answer your queries
through Google Search
to upload your photos.
One of my favorite
things is this.
You see the GIF of the shark.
Dare I say it's shark-proof
networking, too?
By some estimates, it
carries as much as 40%
of the world's internet
traffic every day.
That's for your
queries, YouTube,
all that kind of good stuff.
So what are some of
the cool technologies
that you can use that you're
going to see and practice
a little bit later in your labs?
And here's a demo that
I'd like to show you using
one of my favorite APIs,
or Application Programming
Interfaces, using the
machine learning model
for identifying images.
This is my wife, my
daughter, and myself.
And earlier in the year,
we were in New York City.
This is just a
couple of months ago.
And it was freezing.
As you can see,
we're bundling up
in front of the
Statue of Liberty.
So I took this
photo, and I wanted
to see what machine learning can
tell me about it without having
to build a model myself.
So I uploaded it into what's
called the Vision API.
And immediately,
it says, I think
this object here is a landmark.
With 79% certainty, I think
it's the Statue of Liberty.
Also, I'm going to recognize
the faces in the photo.
And I recognize that
there's two faces.
But beyond that, I can
see in my wife's face,
because she's a veteran of cold
weather, joy is very likely.
My daughter, on the other
hand, joy is very unlikely
because she was freezing.
But what it did show
that was very likely
that she was wearing a hat.
So for common applications,
like working with images,
processing out what's
in that image content,
there's a lot of
pre-built models.
Machine learning is just a way
to get computer intelligence
based on a lot of
good training data.
And it also recommends
some kind of objects
that are in the photo
as well, and sends
some descriptive labels,
as you see as I open up
the labels in here as well.
And that just shows us
a general application
of machine learning.
You can see that it says, if
I looked up this image online,
it would recommend that it
was the Statue of Liberty.
You can access this yourself
if you're a developer,
and you don't want
to just drag and drop
an image into the web UI.
This is the JSON request
that you can just hit
against this API endpoint here.
And this is the response
that you can get.
Why does that matter?
Well, the really cool part is
if you didn't want to just do
one photo at a time,
what you can do
is that you can actually
send a batch request
for thousands of photos.
So what I decided to
do next was I said,
all right, let me find a
public collection of images.
And the Met had a
really good one.
And let's take a look
at over 200,000 images
at the same time, and
then feed all of them
through the Vision API and
see what we come up with.
So we're using two
technologies here.
It's the Vision API to
get us whether or not
joy or surprise or anger is
likely inside of these photos.
And it's BigQuery to
store all of that data
and allow us to query it.
You don't really have to worry
about too much of the SQL
and the queries here.
I'll provide you the
queries after the fact.
I'll share this demo
with you as well.
But you can see for each
of these images here,
we've got the image
URL, and we also
have the Vision API's data.
So if you remember that
JSON response that showed
whether or not something was--
like my daughter
was wearing the hat,
or if it was a
particular landmark,
or if there's
likelihood of surprise,
you get that response, and you
can query those 200,000 images
to do some really cool things.
So this query inside
of BigQuery says,
what are the different
possible attributes for joy?
And as you saw where was
the highlighted squares,
the shades of green, you can see
it was very likely to likely.
In this section of code,
what this does is this shows,
find me the image where
surprise is most likely
from just an image of artwork.
These are literally just
photos, and the machine says,
I think this piece of
art looks surprised.
And it says with about
a 54% confidence.
Again, you can kind of filter
for your own thresholds.
But this is one piece of
the artwork [INAUDIBLE]..
And maybe it's
probably a surprise.
This is an Italian pottery
vendor from the Met collection.
[INAUDIBLE] surprised
because he's
carrying way too many
pots, and he's probably
going to break them.
But you can see you
can tie in both the
doing insights at scale
through machine learning
and also querying them
inside of BigQuery.
Now, I'm super biased because,
as you saw in my background,
this is all data.
But you can imagine doing this
in your applications as well.
Here's another
example, 98% confident
that-- they just fed this
image, and this image, it says,
is Yosemite.
And I can tell you
right now, on the right,
you can see that
mountain right there.
That's El Capitan here in
Yosemite National Park.
That is a heck of a climb
up Half Dome as well, too.
But you can see just
even without writing
a lot of custom machine
learning model code,
there are these tools that
you can reach out and get--
that allow you to get the
full benefit of Google Cloud
Platform.
Now you may be
wondering, OK, you
showed us a couple
of toy examples
of photos from vacation and
photos from the library.
How is Google actually using
these for our customers today?
So a really cool
application that I like
is Keller Williams, who is
US real estate and realtor
company.
What they allow their
professionals to do
is if you're a
real estate agent,
and you're selling
houses, normally
if you're going on a
website, and you're
a customer who wants
to buy a house,
you want to learn a little
bit about the features
of the house.
Does it have
granite countertops?
Does it have crown
molding, anything
that you want to care
about for a house.
But manually going
through and tracking
the inventory for every
single house's appliance
is a super boring job.
So one of the things
that you can do
is you can point
your smartphone--
they've developed this
application built on top
of Google Cloud AutoML Vision--
and point this smartphone
around at the house,
and let it take that video.
And then it'll automatically
recognize objects
and say, oh, this house
is in a modern style.
Or I recognize that these
are granite countertops.
And then it can turn
that automatically
into a demo video.
So you can just
see like, we went
from identifying whether
or not you're wearing a hat
or not to just really
getting a full picture of all
of the things that
make up a house.
And you can see that it's
much faster and possibly more
accurate, and then
doing it yourself.
Also if you didn't like
working with images
and you've got a
lot of natural text,
maybe you're Ocado, which is
the UK's largest online grocery
supplier.
And you want to filter certain
messages that are coming in
for their sentiment.
So someone sends something
like positive sentiment.
Ocado, I love your website.
It's easier for me to do
shopping online, which
is great.
But what happens if someone
sent in a chat saying, hey,
I'm really worried
that the rain is
going to affect my shipment
for fresh vegetables.
Can you make sure that
they arrive on time?
Maybe that sentiment is a
little bit more negative,
or something bad happened
with the shipment.
You can proactively
route those messages
based on their sentiment
to the right person.
So that's another example.
One last one.
Back to images, if you're
doing things manually,
or there's a
process by which you
think you can teach
a machine to do it,
this is another good
example for you.
So Kewpie uses machine learning
to sort out essentially
what's going to be the
ingredients for baby food.
So if you can teach the
machine by showing it
lots of good examples
of what good food looks
like and bad food looks like--
in machine learning, we call
that creating a training data
set--
then you can train
a model to help you,
help the human that's doing
these manual reviews possibly
do it faster as well.
And that's exactly
what they do there.
So that's a lot of
cool applications,
but well, now let's transition
to how you can actually
get those skills and
get the mental map
for the different avenues
that you could pursue inside
of the cloud.
SOWMYA KANNAN: These are some
really powerful use cases
and applications using
Google Cloud Platform, Evan.
So thank you for
walking us through that.
Gartner has placed Google
Cloud Platform in the leader's
quadrant, as has Forrester.
Forrester recognizes
Google Cloud
as a leader in a few different
domains such as Cloud Data
Security, Cloud Native
Full Stack Cloud Platforms,
as well as database
as a service.
So how can you tap into these
opportunities with Google Cloud
and build some of
the cool applications
that Evan showed us?
The best way to get started is
to learn and build something.
And you're talking to
just the right people.
And we have role-based
learning parts
that you can leverage to start
learning about Google Cloud
technologies.
So as you can see here, we have
various role-based learning
parts related to business, cloud
infrastructure, application
development, data
and machine learning,
as well as team collaboration.
Each of these has a
few different roles,
depending on whether you're
an entry level developer,
or you've been around the
block for a few more years.
And you bring that
broader expertise,
and you're really a
practitioner of technologies,
and you've built both
the business acumen
and translating the business
need into a technical solution,
right?
So there's a variety
of training options
that are available
to you that you can
leverage to start ramping up.
If you're trying
to switch careers,
and you're wondering what is the
foundational knowledge that I
need to get started in
one of these career paths,
generally, if you're in the
Cloud Native application
development space
or you're looking
at cloud infrastructure,
a good place to start
might be JavaScript.
And Python skills are a
really good solid foundation.
SQL, like Evan talked about,
SQL skills give you a leg up.
And some Bash Shell
scripting chops
will take you a long way with
cloud infrastructure skills
as well.
And you can't go
wrong by scaling up
on open source technologies,
such as Kubernetes
and TensorFlow.
Those really give you
transferable skills
that you can apply in
multi-cloud environments.
And that's where most
enterprises are going today
with open source technologies
and multi-cloud or hybrid cloud
environments.
EVAN JONES: Absolutely.
One of the things I'll
tag onto the end of there
is when we're
doing resume review
for the people that apply for
a lot of Google positions, one
of the things that I often
look for is on your resume,
naturally, people have links to
their phone number or an email.
Increasingly so, people
are looking for the links
to their GitHub account.
And that's not only can you
consume these open source
technologies, but if
you build something,
even just like a demo
application for school
or for one of your
own personal projects,
and you show that not only
are you passionate about doing
these games and
taking these labs,
but it's kind of like a
capstone project or an ending,
end-of-the-year project
for your courses.
If you're able to
show that code,
then somebody can
immediately say,
wow, they really have taken
not only from learning,
but to the actual application.
And that's what we're going
to be practicing today
is getting you the skills
to build those applications
by starting from
a lab [INAUDIBLE]..
SOWMYA KANNAN: So I just
want to add that cloud career
paths aren't limited to
the technical roles that
are shown here, right?
There are also
various other careers,
such as technical program
management, technical account
management, technical
writers, technical curriculum
developers, like Evan is today,
and I've been for several years
before I moved into this role.
All of those with those roles,
if you have technical skills
that give you a leg up, you're
able to build a more persuasive
case and appear more
confident when you're talking
to business stakeholders.
With those roles, you also need
additional skills, soft skills
such as in leadership,
influencing stakeholders,
project management,
communication, and presentation
skills, and so on.
But there's a place for
everybody in respect
to cloud related careers.
EVAN JONES: Absolutely.
Yeah, well said.
Well said.
You need to really
be well-rounded.
All right, let's talk
about the benefits.
SOWMYA KANNAN: Yeah, so
training and certification
differentiate you from the
rest of the candidate pool.
So there are tons
of opportunities,
and then there are tons
of candidates as well.
So how can you
differentiate yourself
from the rest of the population?
When you complete a Google Cloud
specialization on Coursera,
you have the option to share
your resume with Google Cloud,
as well as our hiring partners.
So go ahead and
take the training,
complete the whole
specialization.
The specialization is
usually a set of courses,
really in-depth training
related to a topic.
In addition, get certified.
Certification, again,
differentiates you
from the rest of the population
and proves to employers
that you meet a certain bar.
In a recent study,
we found that 80%
of those who applied
for a new job
received at least one job offer.
One in three certified
users received a raise
or acquired a job
for higher pay.
So these are some
really great stats,
which show the value
of Google Cloud
training and certification
and enable you to tap
into the careers in cloud.
EVAN JONES: I love those stats.
OK, so how can you get
hands-on experience
working with these
technologies right now?
And we're going to do it
in less than a half hour.
So again, at any
point, by the way,
you're going to follow
along with me live here.
I'm going to explain how
the game is going to work.
But if you have any
questions, we're
going to post promotional
links and anything else
in that discussion thread.
So make sure you let
your voice be heard.
So Qwiklabs, what is Qwiklabs?
And Qwiklabs is essentially
a Sandbox environment.
It's a company that Google
acquired a couple of years
back.
And it's a really
awesome technology.
It's essentially a
platform for training.
And what it's going to
allow you to do as you're
going to practice literally
right after this slide is it's
going to create a real Google
Cloud Platform account for you
to then do the labs.
So you're going to have two
screens open, or two tabs.
You're going to have the
instructions for the lab.
I handpicked my
five favorite labs.
And you're going to have
the real Google Cloud
Platform in the other window.
So let's take a
look at what that's
going to look like
inside of our game.
So before that, I'm
going to introduce you.
I already showed you
a bit about BigQuery.
It's essentially a
really awesome place
to run your SQL on the cloud.
It's a data warehouse that
scales to petabytes of data,
but we'll cover that a lot
more inside of the game.
Because I really want to get
you inside of the technology.
So what we are we going to
be doing inside of the game?
So the game is going to
be one of the five labs.
The whole game itself
is the five labs.
But we're going to be
doing one together.
And I wrote this lab last year.
And what I really
wanted to show people
was the power of doing
machine learning was just
writing a teeny bit of code.
Literally, it's going to
be create or replace model.
And then you pick a model
type, which is pretty awesome.
And the problem that we're
going to solve for our marketing
analysts are--
and this is using real Google
Merchandise Store website
data, Google Analytics
data, and this
is the website where you can
go to buy cool Google shirts.
But our problem is we want
to say which customers, based
on their behavior on our
site, where they came from,
are most likely to come back
and buy something from us.
Now, if you're a marketer,
that's super valuable.
Because then you could say,
hey, you abandoned your cart,
and everyone who's been
on the e-commerce world
knows these kind of tricks
of marketers, right?
If you've added a
product to the card,
and you haven't been to
the website in a while,
or if you're a loyalty user,
you might get special perks
and discounts.
We would really want to identify
those high value visitors
and then promote to them.
How can we do that
with machine learning?
So before we do that, we need
to get you set up for the game.
So highlighted in yellow because
it's probably one of the most
important slides that
you're going to see today,
I'd like everybody to
go to google.qwiklabs--
Q-W-I-K-L-A-B-S-- .com/games/75.
This is our 75th game.
This is the best part of my job.
Now you're going to
be met with a modal.
After you click on
Join Game, a pop-up
will say, hey, knock
knock, what's the password?
The password for
today's 12 hour game--
and again, we're just going
to be doing one of the five
labs in the next half hour--
is kickstart.
Kickstarting your career in
cloud-- all lower lowercase.
It's case sensitive.
So make sure you've got that.
I'll leave this up
for a few more seconds
while we talk a little
bit more about the game.
So as everyone's doing
that now, what the game is,
is you're going to be scoring
points based on completing
objectives in five labs.
And we'll walk through
what these objectives are
for the labs that we're
going to be covering.
And it'll make a lot more sense.
So don't panic, though.
If you're like, oh, I
don't want to just--
doing a lab inside
of a 20-minute window
is too stressful.
You've got 12 hours to take
each of these five labs
as many times as you want.
Now yes, if you go
through a lab really,
really quickly, you get
bonus points for speed,
and then you can show
up on the leaderboard.
But we're going to walk
through one of the labs
that you see together now.
I'm going to be going a little
bit slower because I really
want to teach you a little bit
about the technology as well.
But again, on your own
time for the next 12 hours,
this game window's
going to be active.
And you can take each
of these five labs
that are part of the game.
And they are five of my
absolute favorite labs.
So I'm going to go
ahead and do that now.
So I've opened up the game.
Let me go open this game URL.
I see a few people
already in the game.
I'm this player
number right here.
I want to see this
whole thing fill up.
We've got 300
slots for the game.
You're welcome to just
watch along if you'd prefer,
but it's much more fun to get
in the action and play the game.
On this page after you click
Join Game, click Kickstart.
It will ask you to sign
in with your Gmail account
or create a new
Qwiklabs account.
The cool thing about Qwiklabs
is once you have this account
and you complete these games,
you complete these labs,
you get badges that you
then share on your LinkedIn
or other career site.
So it's a quantifiable way to
say that you have experienced
these technologies.
And the cool part is everybody
that's on the webinar today,
if you complete all
of these labs, you'll
get a special one-time-only edu
badge that our graphic designer
Marissa created, which
is pretty awesome.
And this is literally only going
to be available for the next 12
hours.
And if that doesn't
incentivize you enough,
the top scoring
people for this lab
will also get
additional free credits
to take more labs in the future.
SOWMYA KANNAN: That's awesome.
I didn't realize it was
a limited edition badge.
EVAN JONES: It's
limited edition!
SOWMYA KANNAN: Yeah.
EVAN JONES: Everyone's
ears are perked up now.
It's like, oh,
limited edition badge.
All right, cool.
I mean, if you're not
a competitive person,
and you're a hoarder
like I am, and you just
want to collect cool things,
collect these badges.
I can already see we
added the 300 spots.
We have folks joining.
And again, I'm
going a little bit
slow here just to give
people time on getting there.
If you're at a page
where it says Start Lab,
we're going to be there soon.
SOWMYA KANNAN: Can you repeat
the URL and the access code?
There's a couple of people
on the chat asking for it.
EVAN JONES: Absolutely.
Yeah, no worries.
I'm going to flash this back up.
Everyone just got their
coffee and is coming back.
Wait, wait, wait,
the game's starting.
So before we go on,
make sure everyone's
at the same starting time.
It's going to be
google.qwiklabs--
Q-W-I-K-L-A-B-S-- .com/games/75.
This is only available
for the next 12 hours.
The special code is
kickstart, all lowercase.
And if somebody
wouldn't mind just
pasting this into the discussion
chat, I would be in your debt.
And I'm going to
explain what a lab is.
You're going to see some
timers in just a second.
OK, so going back
to the lab material,
so the entire game
is all five labs.
I'm going to zoom in here.
We're only going to do
one today because we've
got about a half hour
left, and we're going
to do one of my favorite ones.
But how the game works
is you can score points
for completing objectives
in each of the five labs.
In order to get that special
badge, you need to do all five
of the labs.
Now if you look at the
ETA for each of the labs,
it's pretty generous.
So it's 1, 2, 3, maybe
4 or 4 and 1/2 hours.
And honestly, some of these
labs, the fastest people
can do them in about 10 to
15 minutes each as well.
And again, you can take
each lab multiple times.
Why do we keep
saying that you can
take each lab multiple times?
Well, the lab that I
want you to click on
is this one, Predict
Visitor Purchases
with a Classification Model
in BigQuery Machine Learning.
And again, that's
that third lab.
I don't want you to
click on that first one.
You can learn SQL, and BigQuery,
and the basics on your own time
later on today.
What I really want
you to focus on
is this really, really
cool machine learning one.
So everybody click on the
Predict Visitor Purchases
with the Classification Model.
I can see there's a lot of
people already in the game.
Some people are already
getting ready to score points.
I'm at the bottom of
the totem pole here.
So this is the leaderboard.
I can see a bunch of
already people joining in.
So hi from beautiful
Sunnyvale, California.
So what this lab does is as
soon as you click Start Lab, so
let's all do it together.
And don't worry, it won't take
you an hour and 15 minutes.
We're going to do it in
less than 30 minutes.
We're going to
click on Start Lab,
and this is provisioning a
Google Cloud Platform account
for you behind the scenes.
The next thing I want you to do
is open up an incognito window
inside of Chrome.
And once you've
done that, I want
you to go to
console.cloud.google.com.
There's also a big button
inside of the lab that
says Open Google Cloud Console.
Why you want to do it in
an incognito window is
if you use Gmail or if you
use other Google services,
you don't want to sign in
with your personal account
because you're going to
be given a student account
that lets you use the Google
Cloud Platform for free.
And having an
incognito window allows
you to do that without having
to worry about shifting back
between things.
So now what I'm going to
do is I'm going to go back.
I'm going to copy and paste my
username with this little Copy
button right here.
I'm going to paste it in, and
this is different for you.
And then it's going
ask for our password.
It's an auto-generated password.
Don't worry about what
I'm going to do right now.
I'm just going to
quickly hide in CSS,
so nobody can troll
me live on the webinar
unless you can read
one pixel font.
You copy in your password.
And then boom, welcome to
your new Google Cloud Platform
account.
Kind of wild, right?
So let's accept the Terms
of Service together.
And again, once you
do one of these labs,
you'll blaze through
this startup.
It will look super familiar.
It's a new account each time.
Agree to the Terms of Service.
Agree and continue.
And if you're at a place
where you see a big blue bar
at the top that says
Google Cloud Platform,
you know you're in
the right place.
Again, let's review the steps,
console.cloud.google.com
in an incognito window.
So you have two windows open.
You've got your
lab instructions.
And the lab we're doing today
is Predict Visitor Purchases
with a Classification Model
in BigQuery Machine Learning.
You've already
clicked Start Lab.
And then on that open Google
Cloud console in the incognito,
you're not signing in with
your personal Gmail account.
You're signing in with this
auto-generated username
right here.
And you're pasting
that in to sign in.
And then you're coming back and
copy and pasting the password.
And I see a lot of people are
in here, which is excellent.
So now like I mentioned before,
you've got the two screens.
You've got lab instructions
as you start to scroll down.
And these labs are all step
by step by step by step.
So even if you don't
have a background in SQL,
you don't have a background
in machine learning,
absolutely fine.
You're still going to
be able to do the lab
the same way as anybody else.
And the good news is we provide
a lot of links and instruction
to make sure that you're
on the same playing
field as people who are
very experienced in SQL.
So now we've got the
lab instructions.
What I'm going to ask you to
do is have that open in one
window.
In the other window, this is
the real Google Cloud Platform.
Now you only have access to
this project, this platform,
for the duration of the lab.
So you don't get
access to this forever.
So this one is only available
until that timer hits 0
on your Start Lab, End Lab.
So let's go ahead and get
started with the actual game.
So first thing I
want you to do is
make sure we're on our
auto-generated project.
So I'm going to click on in
the upper left hand corner--
I'm going to zoom
in a little bit
so you guys can see
a little bit easier.
Select a project.
And the one that you want should
be all the way at the bottom.
It's Qwiklabs GCP
alphanumeric characters.
A project in Google
Cloud Platform
is essentially a
collection of resources
that you're going to be using.
BigQuery is a resource.
Machine Learning Vision
API is a resource.
So click on that.
And now if you open or
expand the navigation menu,
these are all the
tools in our toolbox
that we can begin to build
really cool applications with.
Now my favorite, since
I'm naturally biased
and I come from a Big Data
background, if you scroll,
scroll, scroll, scroll,
scroll all the way down,
the only one there we're
going to be using today
to do both data analysis and
machine learning is BigQuery.
If you have experience-- and
again, this is under BigData,
BigQuery--
one of the things that you can
do as well is you can pin it.
If you pin it, it
actually bookmarks it
or highlights it all the
way at the top for you.
So if this is your own Google
Cloud Platform and project
account in the future, you can
avoid doing tons of scrolling.
Because there's
tons of products,
but I don't like
scrolling that much.
So let's get into BigQuery.
Welcome to new BigQuery UI.
Great.
Click Done.
Once you're in here,
essentially what
BigQuery allows you
to do-- the left side
is all about what data
you're pulling from.
The right side is
all about what query.
It's a blank canvas,
which is a little bit
terrifying for somebody
who may be rusty at SQL.
Hasn't done it a lot in a while.
So I'm going to get you
over that nervousness
by saying, all capital
letters, SELECT.
I just want you to
say SELECT your name.
And your name is a
string, which just
means it's kind of like
alphabetic characters.
It's not going to
be in numbers, so we
need to put it in single
quotes or double quotes.
As long as you're consistent,
it doesn't really matter.
And I want you to click Run.
If you've never ran
SQL before, you've
now ran your first
SQL statement.
And the crazy part
is you're going
to go from never running a SQL
statement before to running SQL
and building not one,
but two machine learning
models in the next 20 minutes.
It's kind of wild.
So you have your
query right here,
and below, you've got
your query results.
A lot of people might be
wondering, what on earth
is the column F0?
Well, those of you familiar
with SQL, we can add an alias,
which is essentially a
column name, up top here.
And now it's just saying,
hard code this value.
Just return this value, and
then give the column a name.
Boom, and that's how you
get rows and columns.
Now it's not really
that fun with just,
hey, just return
what I'm saying.
We want to pull some data
from an existing data source.
Now you don't have
to do what I'm doing,
but I'm just going to show you.
So I'm going to search for
the Google Merchandise Store.
So the crazy part is this
Google Merchandise Store,
it's literally the store that
sells things like Google pens,
and swag, and that
type of stuff,
which is sometimes prizes for
these games, which is great.
Google does a lot of what
I call dog fooding, which
means they use their products
on their own services
and businesses.
So the Google Merchandise
Store, their Google Analytics
account-- and Google Analytics
is a way of tracking user
behavior on a website,
marketers know all about it--
is actually stored inside of
BigQuery, the actual Google
Analytics account,
which is crazy.
So what I want
you to do is we're
going to delete this query.
And I'm going to go back
to the lab instructions,
and we're going to follow along.
So we've already
done all of this.
We already have
completed the BigQuery.
And what I want you
to do is we will
copy this link, which is
the console.cloud.google.com
with that specific project.
I'm going to go back here.
For ease of use, I'm just
going to open up a new tab
and paste it.
Why are we doing all this?
Because if we have a data
set that already exists,
what you can do is you can
just gain access to it.
This is public, so it's
available to everybody.
Your data sets by
default are naturally
not going to be public,
which is good for you.
But this gives you
access to a data
set that I've already created
that has our Google Analytics
data inside of it.
So now let's continue
on with the lab.
And again, to
repeat that, you've
copied and pasted
this in a new tab.
And then now you're going to
have the actual data insights
data here.
And inside, if you
expand that, you
can actually see some
really cool data sets.
The e-commerce one is going to
be our focus for today's lab.
So let's scroll down.
We're going to explore
the e-commerce data set.
So you can explore
structured data
by using the structured
query language.
SQL is a fancy way of just
asking questions of your data.
So let's ask some questions.
Out of the total visitors who
visited that store that I just
showed you, what
percentage made a purchase?
And before I run this
query, I want a couple
brave souls to answer
in the chat what
you think a high conversion rate
is for an e-commerce website.
So out of 100 people that
visit your shopping website,
how many of them
out of 100 do you
think actually make a
purchase versus just
surf on your website?
So think about that.
Get a number between 1
and 100 inside your head
for a conversion
rate, and then we're
going to calculate it with
SQL just by running this query
that we created for you.
So once you've got
your answer, let's
take a look at what
we actually return.
So out of 741,000 visits,
we have 20,000 purchasers.
If you multiply
this by 100, you'll
see that's 2.69% or 2.7%.
SOWMYA KANNAN: Wow.
That's amazing,
and I wouldn't have
expected it to be that low.
EVAN JONES: Yeah, it's crazy.
SOWMYA KANNAN: Yeah.
But my number in my head was
closer to like 30% or 40%.
EVAN JONES: Woo!
30%?
SOWMYA KANNAN: But
I guess I was wrong.
Yeah.
EVAN JONES: All right, I'm
going to quit Google Cloud
and join Sowmya's business.
You got a 40% conversion rate.
So if you're an
e-commerce professional,
I'm sure some folks have
already answered on chat.
3% to 5% is about would
you expect to convert.
And the cool part
is let's see if we
can't find those people
who may or may not
have bought on
their first visit,
but are likely to buy
in a second visit.
So start to think about
some of the data pieces
that you could know
about a user that's
going to make them
likely to buy, and think
about your own experience.
What behavior would
you kind of do
on the web site that would make
you a kind of loyal customer?
But before we do that,
let's take a look
at some of the products
that we're selling.
So copy and paste--
and again, I'm just--
once you hover over
this black box,
clicking on the Copy button,
and the lab instructions
will be available for you
for the next 12 hours again.
And the lab is a public
lab in the catalog.
So I'm going to give
you the promo link
at the end of this
webinar, where
you get 30 days free Qwiklabs.
So don't worry if you're
worried about like, I'm not
going to lose access
to the instructions
or anything like that.
So top five products--
and again, we're
just doing a sum on
revenue of byproduct.
In this particular case,
a lot of Nest products
are super popular.
And you can see the total
amount that were sold
and the actual revenue,
which is pretty wild.
And you can see the
most popular one
is the thermostat followed by
the outdoor security camera.
People don't want people
breaking into their houses.
And if they do, next
best thing is indoor.
And then they're worried
about smoke less apparently.
That's not Google approved talk.
So how many visitors
bought on subsequent visits
to the website?
So we're going to copy
and paste this one,
and this is where
the foundations
of our objective for the
machine learning model
is going to come into play.
So you don't need to really
worry too much about the code.
But it's just saying if
they've made a transaction,
there's a field in
Google Analytics.
And by the way, this schema--
a schema is a fancy way
of saying rows and columns
and what the columns mean--
if the schema for Google
Analytics for this website,
for the Google Analytics
merchandise store,
is the exact same for
any other site that
uses Google Analytics,
so if you want
to work on your own website and
apply this same logic, you can.
The scheme is going
to be the same.
So if they have
future transactions,
how do I know it's future?
Because I'm just going
to tell you right now,
there's a field in this schema
called New Visits is null,
meaning if the New
Visits field is
flagged as 1, that means
that it's their first visit.
If it's blank, then it's
their subsequent visit.
If they bought on a future
visit, flag them as a 1.
We're going to mark
them as a return visit.
So I'm going to show you
what that looks like.
SOWMYA KANNAN: Evan, people
are racing ahead of you.
There's somebody who's
finished the lab.
EVAN JONES: Somebody's
finished the lab already!
Woohoo, you just
finished the lab.
I love it!
Ahmad, you're doing great work.
So the trick to
these labs, again,
is I'm going through
this pretty slowly,
but what you're
going to realize is
after you execute this query--
so you can see we have a split.
These are the visitors.
This is the amount of those
visitors at total populations
will buy on a return visit.
And we want to be
able to predict that.
I love that people are
racing ahead in the lab.
That's cool.
So inside of the Qwiklabs, how
you can earn the most points,
by the way, is there are certain
milestones where you click
a button, and it says, hey, have
you completed the lab steps up
until this checkpoint?
The faster you actually
run through the lab
and click those, you get a
speed bonus for your points
over here on the right.
So you can say Ahmad
is just crushing it
with 72 million
points right here.
And don't worry
if you feel like,
Evan, you're purposely holding
us back by going so slowly.
Don't worry, you've
got 12 hours.
You can always--
don't do this now--
but when you're
done with this lab,
you can click End Lab,
and a Start Lab button,
the green button
will be there again.
Fire up the lab,
blaze through it
as fast as he did, and then
try to beat his score as well.
So again, you have
multiple attempts
to take each of these labs.
So let's keep going.
So we want to paste
in the next query.
And the next query, again,
is under Selecting Features
and Creating Your
Training Dataset.
A training dataset for machine
learning is basically saying,
I know a lot of
things in the past.
Can I use those for predictive
power in the future?
So there's a couple of things
that you know about a visitor
when they visit your website.
Are they going to
leave immediately?
In the e-commerce world,
it's called a bounce,
meaning they get to your site,
and less than five seconds
passes, and they're
like, whoa, I
don't want to buy any
Google merchandise.
I was looking for
something else.
And they immediately leave.
And then you might be
thinking-- and this
is where the technology piece
is great, BigQuery is great,
but it's really your
brain and your decision
making power that's
going to be guiding you
through the rest of this lab.
Because I need you
to think about what
are some of the
things that you can
know about a user
for whether or not
they're going to come back
to your website and purchase.
So I just threw
together time on site.
Like, if they spend a ton
of time on your website,
is that a good proxy for
the machine learning model
to learn the behavior?
If they spent five hours
my website or three hours,
maybe they're really interested.
Maybe they're not.
So I want you to
think about what
I'm going to show you here.
We're going to
build a model using
just two of these columns.
By the way, in machine
learning speak,
if you're feeding in
inputs to the model--
these are your columns
or your inputs--
those are just called
features of the model.
Features, inputs,
columns all mean
the same thing for our
structured data use case.
So now you're a machine
learning scientist now,
which is pretty cool.
So think.
We're just passing in two
fields and saying if you know
the bounces and the time on site
historically-- because again,
good quality training data is
the foundation for any machine
learning model--
can I predict what I'm going
to buy in a future visit?
And you can see that
even though they
spend 15,000 seconds or
three hours on the site,
they didn't buy on
the return visit.
So what I'm going to show you
and the big crux of this talk
is that it's easy to create
a machine learning model.
It's hard to create a
good high performing
machine learning model.
But we're going to
create one nonetheless
on just those three columns.
So what I want
you to do first is
we need a place to
store those models.
We're going to create
what's called a data set.
So everybody click
on the project.
This is your project.
Don't click on Data Insights.
That's my project.
Click on Create Data Set.
A data set is just a container.
It's a container for
tables, models, views.
And I want you to
call it e-commerce.
You have to call it
e-commerce if you
want to use my queries in the
lab, or else, it'll break.
So make sure you type in
e-commerce all lowercase.
Create a data set.
Once you've done that,
you can click Go To,
or you can toggle this open.
It's got nothing
in there right now.
So let's fill it
up with a model.
So from here on out, we're going
to go a little bit quicker.
So I'm going to delete the
query that I had before.
I'm pasting in the same query.
So in BigQuery,
what you can do is
I've highlighted row
8 through the end.
I can click the down arrow.
I can run the selected.
I'm passing in data to a
machine learning model.
What data are we passing in?
And again, you've
seen this before.
It's just looking to
see whether or not
I have my time on site
in my-- whether or not
they balance immediately
as a good predictive power.
So I've got that.
And now I want to create a model
off of that, so the model code.
Everybody on this
call can create
a machine learning
model, and you're
going to do it right now.
The code is just saying
create your place model.
Store it in my e-commerce,
data set that you just created.
Call it classification model.
This is going to be
model number one, which--
spoiler alert-- it's going to be
a really bad performing model.
We're using logistic regression.
You don't really
need to know this.
There's more
information in the labs,
but logistic regression
is a good model option
if you're doing what's
called classification.
Classification is
saying, I have one class
of users that say I'm going
to purchase on a return visit.
I have another class of users
that aren't going to purchase.
I've got two different buckets.
For a new user that's
coming in the future,
which bucket do they fall into?
It's called classification.
A model type is
essentially a bunch of math
that goes on behind the scenes.
Logistic regression is a
fine one to start with.
And what are we predicting on?
That's your label.
A label is what you
know in the past
and what you're predicting
on in the future.
So we're feeding in a bunch of
known values for whether or not
they're going to
buy historically.
And in the future, we're going
to be predicting on that value.
So right now, I'm going to
ask you to run that query.
That's going to
create the model.
And what I'm going to ask you
to do, while that's running,
I'm going to ask you to open
up a new tab because I'm
going to get you to create a
second model at the same time.
So we're going to run
two models concurrently,
and I'm going to explain what
the differences between model
one and model two are.
So again, to recap, you've
got one model running.
You can see in query
history one running.
And I've got a blank
canvas right here.
I want you to
scroll down or click
in the sidebar on
the section that
says Improve a Model Performance
with Feature Engineering.
It's a very fancy
way of saying, hey,
those two columns is just
saying whether or not
someone sat on your website
page, your home page
for three hours and not
moved anywhere might not
give a lot of predictive power
to the machine learning model.
Let's see if we can throw
in some additional data.
So you know you're in
the right spot in the lab
if it says, create a replacement
model, e-commerce dot
classification model number two.
So go ahead and copy that code.
Paste that in and then run that.
Machine learning
models, if you haven't
worked with machine
learning before,
some of the best and
the brightest ones
could take hours or even days
for some of the huge models
here at Google.
These models are going to run
in less than five to 10 minutes,
which is absurd when it comes
to creating your first machine
learning model.
SOWMYA KANNAN: So
in the past, I would
have expected that a SQL
programmer would need or would
only be interested
in this kind of data
or be able to produce
this kind of data.
But it now seems like a
marketing analyst or a business
intelligence professional
might be interested.
EVAN JONES: Absolutely.
SOWMYA KANNAN: Or
now has the toolset
to produce those kinds
of predictive analysis
and so on, right?
Which is really amazing.
You're not relying
on your IT teams
anymore to give you the data.
EVAN JONES: That's it.
And that's the biggest shift.
As I mentioned
like 10 years ago,
you had to manage both the
optimization of the database,
like making sure not too many
people are running queries
at the same time
and whether or not
you're going to have enough
storage on your hard drive.
And then you had to rely on
your data science professionals
to create the machine
learning models.
Now literally,
it's a conversion.
We like to call it a
democratization of data.
So your analyst is superpowered.
With just a little bit of
SQL that you just picked up
on this one lab, you can be able
to do just incredible things,
like building your own
machine learning models.
So yeah, the labs are great.
And that's why it's so
fun to teach this stuff.
So while those
models are running,
I'm going to ask you in
that first tab-- cycle
back there-- you know when
it's done when you actually
go into the e-commerce.
I'm toggling this
open and closed.
And you can see that my
classification model,
this first one is finished.
So I'm going to ask you
to click on that one.
And we want to see
how well it did.
So I want you to
click on evaluation.
Oh, this one's still training.
I'm going go and
refresh my browser.
And we'll see how
many of them finish.
There we go.
We got both of them finished.
So if you see it's still
training, oh, good.
Both of them are still running.
So it looks like I created
the shell for the model,
but we still need to wait
for the queries to finish.
Yep, two are still running.
So what you're
going to see here,
let's talk a little
bit about evaluating
the performance of the machine
learning model and the theory.
And by the way, I've been
really lax about doing this,
but make sure that
you actually click
Check My Progress
for each of these,
including creating
the data sets.
This is how you get
the speed bonus points.
So let's talk about evaluating
a machine learning model.
Now, you might ask, how
do you know whether or not
a classification
model was good or not?
An interesting scenario
for classification models
is there's a couple of
different metrics you can say.
A lot of people say accuracy.
If my machine learning
model is 98% accurate,
is that a good thing?
So the really cool
learning part here
is you know the conversion
rate for an e-commerce website
is about 2%.
So if your model predicted that
every single new person is not
going to buy--
very simple model, whatever
the data that came in, it says,
this person's not going to buy--
you'd only be wrong
2% of the time.
That means have a 98% accurate
machine learning model.
But is it any good?
Absolutely not.
Because we have what's
called a class imbalance.
You've got only 2% of the
people in the positive class,
98% of people in
the negative class.
So accuracy is not
necessarily the best metric.
So there's some other metrics.
One's called the receiver
operator characteristic,
or the area under the curve.
I linked some Wikipedia
articles in there
for you to learn about that.
All that essentially
means is you
want to maximize the true
positive rate as fast
as possible, meaning when
I say they're going to buy,
they're going to buy.
When I say they're
not going to buy,
they're not going to buy,
while at the same time,
minimizing the
false positive rate.
And you want to maximize, if
you remember your calculus--
you don't have to do
any of that here--
but it's the area
under the curve.
The highest, if you can imagine
this yellow curve right here,
if it filled up this entire
square, it's just 1 by 1,
so the area of that is 1.
A 1.0 is perfect, an
area under the curve.
And that's where you can see
if it's greater than 0.9,
it's good.
Essentially anything
less than 0.7
is a really terribly
performing model.
So let's go back and check
on each of our models.
And then we'll do
a quick wrap up.
So back in BigQuery, I'm just
going to refresh very quickly.
And you can see--
let's see-- both
models are done.
I can see they're both running.
Let's check on the first model.
Evaluation, 0.78.
Again, we're looking for
that super healthy uptick
for their precision
and over time.
So 0.78, can we do a little
bit better than that?
And again, this is new
as of a couple of months
ago that they show you
these graphs, which is cool.
And you can just copy and
paste these in your slide deck
and just show,
hey, I did a model.
Here's the valuation.
0.78 compared to
0.92, so you see,
just look at the difference in
the precision recall curves.
And again, it's still a
hard problem to solve.
So we're going to flip
back between the two.
So this one is a little
hump, and then way down.
This one gives you a
little bit more lift,
but again, perhaps we
could add some more
features in the model.
And machine learning is
an iterative process.
You've got to be
comfortable with failure.
That's essentially
how a model works.
It says, all right.
I know this for the past.
Here are my inputs.
Am I going to get
a good result based
on running this over a
million records or not?
So it essentially-- and what
the process is called gradient
descent--
it will fail, fail, fail,
fail, fail until it gets
to a point where, OK, cool.
I think I've modeled the
behavior of one of these users
effectively.
So you've done exactly all
the steps a machine learning
scientist would do.
The last part is
understanding the differences
between those two models.
So what do we actually do?
So the only thing that we
did for this second model--
I asked you to blindly
run the code and now
I'm going to explain it
to you a little bit more--
is where you evaluated the
performance of the first one,
we already did the evaluation.
Make sure you actually
run the evaluation query.
You can get those graphs
either through this the SQL
or by clicking on
the Evaluation tab.
If you're going for
points, make sure
that you actually run these,
and then click the check points.
What did we actually do?
So the second model is
the exact same model code.
So at the top, it's the same
model code, same model type.
It's not like we're
using a neural network
or anything like that here.
But what we're doing
is machine learning
models are like spaceships
and rocket ships, right?
And the data is the fuel.
If you're not feeling them
with enough high quality
good training data, they're
not going to go anywhere.
So what do we add?
Well, in addition to
the time on the site
and whether or not
they left immediately,
we also added how
many pages they
viewed, where they came
from, what traffic source,
whether or not they were
on mobile or desktop,
what country they came from.
And the good news is
you don't need to create
a ton of if statements.
If they're in this country,
and they're on mobile,
and they've been to six pages,
and they viewed this one
particular promotion,
then I think
I want to make them
a high level user.
No if statement, no
CASE statement logic.
Just show the model of
the data, and let it
do its magic behind the scenes.
So that's one of
my favorite labs.
By the time you
get to the end, you
can actually make sure you
created the second model.
You can run the
predictions on new data
by running that last
predictive query.
Make sure you're
getting all the points.
And then you can see actually
the actual predictions
that it makes and the
confidence in those predictions.
I'll leave that
last part to you.
And you can see
the results there.
And I'll just highlight
that at the end,
you have multiple labs that you
can take multiple times as part
of this game, every 12
for this 12 hour period.
We do games all the time.
So twitter.com/Qwiklabs.
Every Friday, we do
one of these new games,
which is pretty cool.
And you can try each of
these different labs.
So for example,
if your background
is more on the
infrastructure side,
and you want to work
with Kubernetes,
this last lab is awesome.
You can spin up a
Kubernetes cluster
and actually scrape Reddit,
one of the subreddits,
for, like, cute dog
and cat pictures,
and then display those in
a web app that you create.
So last thing before I go, you
made it all the way to the end.
I do want to share a
promotional code with you.
And I'll paste
this into the chat.
So the game is
open for 12 hours.
And you have got those five labs
that Sowmya and I handpicked
to put in there.
But what happens after
the 12 hours ends?
You can take more
labs, but kudos to you
for attending this webinar.
We're to give you
a 30 day free pass,
or one month free, if
you have this link.
And it's a little bit hard to
write down, so I'll make sure
that I post it in chat.
But it's
google.qwiklabs.com/quests/23/
and the query string is Qwiklabs
campaign is one quarter 30 day
96.
So I'll paste that in the chat.
I'll make sure that we get
that pasted into there.
So make sure you don't leave
without the link to the game,
the Qwiklabs promotion here.
And honestly, just
have a blast with them.
SOWMYA KANNAN: Could
we just quickly
show them the other higher
education benefits as well?
So if you're a student in
higher ed, here are some links.
So you might want
to screenshot this,
and we'll make sure that we put
this information in the chat
as well.
We have some great career
readiness offerings
that you can leverage
to get started
with the discounted training
and certification as well.
So Evan and I have
thoroughly enjoyed our talk,
thanks to the webinar crew here
and [INAUDIBLE] our program
coordinator, [? Nandini, ?]
our [INAUDIBLE] moderator.
This would not
have been possible
without the team support.
So thank you very
much for joining us.
And thank you for tuning in.
Please visit Cloud OnAir for
more content from Google Cloud
experts.
And thank you, Evan.
I've had a blast here
working with you today.
EVAN JONES: My pleasure.
We'll see you in the game.
Good luck.
[MUSIC PLAYING]